born a slave he rose to become a
prominent abolitionist statesman author
and respected figure around the world
the most photographed african-american
of the 19th century he was also a
recognizable figure even as his very
identity put him at risk for much of his
life Frederick Douglass's story is one
of perseverance intellect and an
unending desire for freedom and justice
[Music]
Frederick Douglass wasn't born with that
name nor was he born on the day that he
later adopted as his birthday at birth
he was christened Frederick Augustus
Washington Bailey the date he was born
has been lost to history but later in
life he decided that February the 14th
would be the day on which he marked his
entrance into the world he said I have
no accurate knowledge of my age never
having seen any authentic record
containing it is what he wrote in a
narrative of the life of Frederick
Douglass we do know though that Douglass
was born into slavery in Maryland's
likely the son of a union between his
mother and their owner Douglass's mother
was known for her intelligence and is
widely considered to be the only slave
who could read or write in the area of
Maryland where she lived
but Douglass never really got to know
his mother it was common for infants
born to slaves to be separated from
their mothers soon after birth taking
care of children took up energy and time
that the younger woman could use to
doing hard work on the farm or the
plantation old women who weren't able to
do such physical labor could take care
of children and slave masters wouldn't
see a drop in productivity so Douglass
like many slaves he grew up without his
mother
he was sent to live with his grandmother
Betty Bailey she was also the caretaker
for 12 other children Douglass's mother
was enslaved at a different plantation
he only saw her a handful of times
before he was removed from his
grandmother's house but around age 7
Douglass was separated from the family
that he knew he was taken from his
grandmother's home and was sent to why
plantation at white plantation he joined
a thousand other slaves spread across 20
farms owned by master Lloyd Douglass he
didn't work in the fields he was still
young and so he didn't go out
instead he cared for the family's cows
and tended to the houses garden and it's
yacht it was while he was at this farm
that his mother died and then once again
Douglass was uprooted as a slave
Douglass was forced to move and serve at
the whims of his masters this time he
was sent to Baltimore to serve the
family of Hugh auld here
Douglass followed in his mother's
footsteps he learned to read and write
his journey to literacy started when
Sophia old Hugh's wife began teaching
him the letters of the alphabet it was
unusual for a slave owner to take so
much entry
in the education of a slave and he all
did not like that his wife was doing so
thus all thought that if slaves could
read and write they would be more likely
to want their freedom and more likely to
seek it out Douglas called olds
arguments against literacy his first
decidedly anti-slavery lecture
unfortunately Sophia came around to her
husband's way of thinking and Douglass's
tutoring sessions they came to an end
but Douglas believed that once you learn
to read you will be forever free and so
he kept learning he taught himself to
read grabbing any publication that had
words on it newspapers and political
pamphlets joins books in his collection
and Douglass began to learn much more
than how to read he was learning about
the events of the country and the rest
of the world among the publication's he
devoured was the Columbian orator this
book was an 18th century anthology that
was used as a literacy teaching tool in
classrooms for Douglass though the book
offered more than just a lesson in
reading and writing it gave him an
insight into ideas about freedom and
about human rights Douglass he didn't
want to keep the power of literacy to
himself though he started teaching other
slaves from nearby plantations to read
during Sunday school using the New
Testament dozens of slaves would show up
each week to learn amazingly this went
unnoticed for nearly six months but when
it was discovered that Douglass was
teaching fellow slaves to read and write
the slave owners were beside themselves
with anger one Sunday while Douglass was
teaching the fuming owners burst into
the makeshift school they were intent
that their slaves would not learn to
read and write and they used violence to
get their point across they used stones
and clubs to ends that Sunday meeting
and to end Douglass's teaching for the
time being
Douglass was still a teenager when this
happens and he was already beginning to
make his mark on the world by the time
Douglass hit his teens he had also been
moved from owner to owner and plantation
to plantation several times in his late
teens Douglass was sent to be a slave
for Edward Co V Co he subjected to
Douglass to violence regularly beating
and whipping him in his book my bondage
and my freedom Douglass entitles the
chapter devoted to his time on Covey's
plantation as Co V the Negro breaker
he writes of the beatings he sustained
at Covey's hands I had not been in his
possession three whole days before he
subjected me to
most brutal chastisement under his heavy
blows blood flowed freely and whales
were left on my back as large as my
little finger the sores on my back from
this flogging continued for weeks for
they were kept open by the rough and
coarse cloth which I wore for shouting
eventually Douglas began to fight back
he gave Kody a taste of his own medicine
and the man never tried to use violence
to control Douglass again Douglass knew
he couldn't continue life as a slave
beyond his own beliefs and desire for
freedom he had also met a woman who
inspired him to seek his own freedom and
Maria was a free black woman from
Baltimore she not only inspired
Douglass's freedom but fell in love with
him the two of them they later got
married in 1836 Douglass first attempted
to escape from slavery when his plan was
discovered he was thrown in jail
returned to his owner Douglass remained
a slave for two more years before he was
able to make another escape attempt on
September the 3rd 1838 Douglass took the
risk that he knew could either start his
life as a free man or end it altogether
I felt assured that if I failed in this
attempt my case would be a hopeless one
it would seal my fate as a slave forever
he later wrote had obtained papers
showing him to be a free man a risky
move in and of itself the vapors
belonged to a black sailor and so
Douglass had to act the part
if he wanted to be successful before
leaving his master's property in
Baltimore Douglass costumes himself in
red shirt black cravat and a sailor's
hat while he disguised himself with
sailors clothes the plan still had one
big flaw Douglass wasn't a great
physical match for the description on
the papers if an official stopped to
closely consider the measurements in the
description his journey to freedom would
be over Douglass boarded a train to
Philadelphia and as expected he faced in
an inspection when he was asked to show
free papers Douglass handed over his
sailors identification and said I never
carry my free papers to sea with me if a
paper with the American Eagle on it that
will carry me around the world the
answer and the papers were enough for
the conductor Douglass was free to stay
on the train and to continue his journey
but he still had to make it through
slave states where he risked getting
arrested after an anxious
Douglas stepped off the train in New
York and made his way to a group of
underground railroad activists he was in
a free state but he was not a free man
he was technically a fugitive so could
still be arrested the danger was
definitely not over frame yet
nevertheless he was ecstatic
to simply be in one of these free states
I've often been asked how I felt when
first I found myself on free soil there
is scarcely anything in my experience
about which I could not give a more
satisfactory answer a new world had
opened upon me if life is more than
breadth and the quick round of blood I
lived more in one day than in a year of
my slave life it was a time of joyous
excitement which words can but tamely
describe the Underground Railroad
activists provided him shelter for a day
and got word to his beloved Ana that he
was free she made her way up from
Baltimore and that he were married in
New York within days the couple were off
further north to Massachusetts where
life was somewhat safer for a fugitive
slave there was still prejudice however
in Douglas had to work hard to find even
menial jobs where he could earn a living
while in New Bedford Douglass became a
licensed preacher and he taught Sunday
School and served as church sexton he
also became involved in the abolitionist
movement Douglass was inspired by
abolitionist William Lloyd Garrison and
avidly read his newspaper The Liberator
the first time Douglass was asked to
speak as an abolitionist a meeting he
was frightened he had been unexpectedly
asked to give a speech at the
Massachusetts anti-slavery societies
national convention through his
nervousness he gave an incredibly
eloquent and thoughtful speech unlike
the white abolitionists who gave most
anti-slavery speeches douglass could
speak personally about the pain and the
brutality of slavery Douglass's skill at
public speaking it was quickly noticed
and he talked more and more at
anti-slavery meetings and soon he was a
key part of the abolitionist movement at
meetings he would tell his story and
rouse crowds to the course in 1843 he
joined the American anti-slavery society
to tour the Midwestern United States and
speak about the importance of abolishing
slavery they traveled for six months
spreading their message and in doing so
often putting themselves in danger this
was two decades before the Civil War and
slavery supporters wanted to make
themselves hurt
they turned violence on some occasions
and Douglass had his hand broken during
one
Meli in indiana douglas didn't just put
his oratory skills to work for the
abolitionist movement though he also
wrote his autobiography telling the
story of what it was like to grow up and
live his slave titles narrative the
autobiography of Frederick Douglass the
book was a huge success it had nine
reprinting 's and was translated so that
it could be sold in europe as well the
success of the book they came with a
cost though it attracted attention to
Douglass and he was still not a free man
in the eyes of the law instead of going
into hiding in the United States though
Douglass headed to Europe then he was
safe from arrest and could continue
spreading his message and telling his
story during a two-year tour of England
and Ireland he raised his profile both
back home and in Europe crowds came to
see him speak and such was his appeal
that his European supporters began
raising money to buy his freedom in
America Douglass was also impressed with
Europe he was treated like a person
there unlike he was at home instead of a
democratic government I am under a minar
kacal government instead of the bright
blue sky of America and covered with the
soft gray fog of the Emerald Isle I
breathe and lo the chattel becomes a man
I goes around in vain for one who will
question my equal humanity claim me as
his slave or offer me an insult
I find myself regarded and treated at
every turn with the kindness and
deference paid to white people when I go
to church I'm met by no upturned nose
and scornful lip to tell me we don't
allow niggers in here his supporters
were successful in raising the funds to
buy Douglass's freedom and he was able
to return to America to his wife and to
the cause of freeing the millions of
slaves in the country he started
publishing his own paper the North Star
and also took up causes of freedom
beyond the abolitionist movement he
spoke at the women's rights Seneca Falls
convention calling for women to be
granted the right to vote he also became
active in calling for the desegregation
of schools this is a full century before
brown and Board of Education was decided
by the Supreme Court
because of his activism and his
perpetual presence in the abolitionist
and other movements Douglass was a
highly recognized figure in America when
the Civil War began during the war
Douglass was a fierce advocate of
allowing African Americans to fight for
the Union a war undertaken and brazenly
carried for the petrel enslavement of
the colored man calls logically and
loudly for the colored men to help
suppress it Douglass even had the year
of Abraham Lincoln and was able to speak
to the president about his views on
African American troops he used his
publications and speeches to call for
the inclusion of African Americans in
the army for two years he kept working
on this issue in 1863 Lincoln issued the
Emancipation Proclamation and African
Americans were free to join the army
Douglass and his family were ready two
of his sons signed up to fight and a
third became active in recruitment
Douglass himself shifted his message
from encouraging the inclusion of
African Americans in the military to
encouraging African Americans to sign up
to fight when times ample curtain shall
fall upon our national tragedy and our
hillsides and valleys Johnny the red and
with the bloods nor white and with the
bones of kinsmen and countrymen who have
fallen in the sanguinary and wicked
strife when grim-visaged war hath
smooth'd his wrinkled front and our
country shall have regained its normal
condition as a leader of nations in the
occupation and blessings of peace and
history shall record the names of heroes
and martyrs who bravely answered the
call of patriotism and liberty against
traitors thieves and assassins let it
not be said that in the long list of
glory composed of men of all nations
there appears the name of no colored man
when the Civil War ended and slavery was
outlawed Douglass did not step away from
public life he believed there was still
much work to be done in the fight for
freedom he was appointed president of
the Freedman's bank which shall promote
economic development in the newly free
african-american communities he also
continued speaking around the country
and was active in supporting ulysses s
grant 1868 campaign for the presidency
then in 1872 Douglass was nominated as
Victoria Woodhull vice-presidential
running mate
he didn't even know had been nominated
he didn't seek it out but the Equal
Rights party but him on the ticket
the less it wouldn't be as last
appearance in a presidential race in
1888 he became the first
african-american to receive a vote for
president at a major party's convention
his fame and his outspoken activism
still made him a target
for sinister activities however the same
year he was nominated as a vice
presidential candidate his family's New
York home was targeted by an arsonist
the family was safe but the fire showed
that he nor his african-american
brethren was still not safe from
violence even years after the Civil War
it ended
Douglas spent the last two decades of
his life in Washington DC where he
served as a United States Marshal with
an appointment from President Hayes he
and Anna lived in a home called Cedar
Hill Anna his first love and his
inspiration for his escape from slavery
died in 1882 Douglass remarried this
time to a much younger white woman his
children were upset as was his new
wife's family during the 1880s he
continued traveling both the country and
the world giving speeches on a number of
political issues he also kept writing
and issued a new edition of his
autobiography in 1881 the life and times
of Frederick Douglass
was his third book he had also published
my bondage and my freedom in 1855 the
political appointments kept coming too
he served in diplomatic positions as a
recorder of deeds for DC in the
Commissioner of the World's Columbian
Exposition Douglass was speaking and
crusading for Rice right until the end
of his life in 1895 he gave a speech at
the National Convention of women in DC
he was incredibly well received but it
was the last speech he would ever give
shortly after the speech he had a heart
attack and passed away he was 77 years
old
thousands paid their respect to this
funeral in DC and Douglass's body was
then returned to Rochester New York
where he was buried next to Ana
frederick douglass risked his life for
freedom not only when he escaped from
slavery but every time he put himself
out there as a public figure advocating
for an end to slavery the right to vote
and civil rights for all we're gonna
leave you today with some of his own
powerful words where justice is denied
where poverty is enforced we're ignorant
prevails and where any one class is made
to feel that society is an organized
conspiracy to oppress robbed and degrade
them neither persons nor property will
be safe so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic if you did
there's a couple of things you could do
right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification
every time every Monday and Thursday we
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]